hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we are going to be talking about
the top mistake developers
make when learning how to code
now this is a special video because this
is actually a
two parter if you want to see the other
part head over
to sydney buckner's channel sydney
buckner is a software engineer and she
too has a channel dedicated to giving
you all
all the insights and the tricks and the
tips and career advice and unsolicited
advice and all of that
on things that will aid in your
transition
into tech and so her video is going to
be linked in the description box below
so make sure after you watch mine you
watch the part
two for all of her helpful tips as well
mistake number one jumping straight
into frameworks when you don't even
know the base language yet this is a
huge problem that
i had i jumped into ruby on rails when
i didn't know any which way what ruby
was and so
that is a really big issue because
that's like trying to
use a calculator meanwhile you don't
know long division
that's a big problem that will really
really affect you and your development
in the future and so the whole
trying to learn react before you even
learn javascript
trying to learn bootstrap yet you've
never done a project with css
that is a huge issue y'all you need to
make sure you understand
the underlying language because then
when you're having troubles
with your framework or developing and
you see bugs that come up
then you have a better avenue of which
way to go
if you know that the ruby principle is x
y and z then you know
which way to look if you had just
started off with frameworks and even if
you do well in everything once you start
encountering bugs and working on
projects and teams
that's really really really going to
screw you over
so make sure we don't skip the basics
and i know
i know when you have this goal of i
will be an engineer by the end of the
year or by 2022 or x y and z
it can feel like oh i have to make sure
i do
x y and z and i have to jump over to
this step and if there's a framework
built
on ruby so what does it matter if i know
the
language itself it matters
it matters so please please please make
sure
you don't skip over those steps don't
skip over those hurdles
and start with the basics html css
ruby javascript start with the basics
the second mistake not practicing
on your own projects
it is so easy to read something or to
watch something
and be like oh yeah that that makes
sense
you know like write it down and okay
bet i'm going to be an engineer by the
end of the week watch
but if you don't actually open up
your own laptop and code these things
out
what you're learning really won't stick
it really won't
when it won't stick and two you'll
realize that
actually what you just read makes no
sense to you because here you are trying
to do it and
why isn't it working and so now you need
to
learn how to actually build those things
out and so
it's so important to practice with your
own projects so you can really make sure
you are learning as much as you can
because that's how you
make sure these skills stay by doing it
yourself
and also keeping track of what made
sense
and what doesn't that way it provides
you a bit of an
avenue of where to go next like okay x
didn't make sense or it didn't work
okay so let's really hone in on this and
really make sure
we can figure it out and then move on to
the next thing
rather than reading reading reading and
moving on moving on moving on
yet you have built nothing so make sure
you build out those projects and
practice
on your own the third thing that is a
huge mistake
is not keeping track of what you're
doing
how you're doing it the problems you're
coming upon i.e
not having a developer journal this is
something that sydney
really hones in on in her video how to
become a better developer
through journaling i'll link it below
and here sydney really goes
through one of the benefits one of those
benefits being
being able to unload your mind it's so
easy to get
so jumbled so quickly and if by
writing the things you're struggling
with down you
kind of gains perspective and say oh
i thought i had 30 000 things in my head
spiraling around really i have two it's
really just two things and so let me
make sure i write these down
cross them off etc also it's important
to keep track
of how you're learning and how their
journey
is going and so by doing this you really
can get a better sense
of what things do you need to work on
more what things are you good on and so
really just have a
better learning journey and so i'll link
that video below
and in that video she also goes into
really how
to go about journaling not just why it's
important but really how to do it in the
most effective manner so really you
don't want to skip that fourth mistake
people will be making y'all will be
making i
have and will be making is not sticking
to
a strict schedule when you were in
school you had a schedule
even if you were in preschool they had a
schedule for you maybe you didn't
realize but they had a schedule for you
and that was because
a schedule is so important to really
make sure you're staying consistent
you're staying on track and it doesn't
mean
when i say have a strict schedule it
doesn't mean load it with eight hours of
you know class time and make sure you
are here by a month from now no but
think about what your timeline is for
your learning journey
and really write it down and write a
schedule for yourself so you can
make sure you're being consistent sydney
has a video on this as well
called how to create a study plan and
this really can
end up making all the difference for
whether you truly succeed at this or
not because y'all coding boot camps are
expensive i'm into a coding bootcamp yo
yo i'm still paying that off it is
expensive
letting your masters getting a bachelor
money
is money and in school when we didn't
abide by our schedule when we were late
we were tardy we
just didn't show up there were certain
repercussions and so it incentivized you
to make sure
you went to those classes went to those
lectures and we're staying
consistent and so why would this be any
different
sure i know you're not in a facility
you're not in a building but it's still
school
you're still trying to learn just like
in school
and if anything it's harder now because
you don't have those people to hold you
accountable so make sure you're holding
yourself accountable
by having an actual robust study plan
and schedule
the fifth mistake i
made like crazy was not being in the
growth mindset in my learning so what
does that mean
y'all i just just me as a person
i tend to be very
end goal oriented it's important to have
goals of course
but when your end goal won't be for
six months a year that's a long time to
go without celebrating your
accomplishments that's a long time to go
without acknowledging that you've
reached a certain
benchmark and so making sure you're in
that growth mindset of
okay i am better this week than i was
last week and
next week i'll be better than i am now
and making
yourself remember these little
accomplishments
and learn for those small incremental
changes and growth it really really
makes all the difference because
now you're mentally rewarding yourself
more you know what i mean and
self-teaching is hard enough
and so imagine going six months without
celebrating your accomplishment without
saying oh wow i'm
here when x amount of days ago or x
amount of weeks ago or months
i was here imagine going a whole six
months without
acknowledging that you've grown and so
make sure you stay in that growth
mindset and don't get stuck on but i
have to get a job within a year
or i have to apply by x y and z in six
months and
x y and z and all of that no you want to
make sure
you are staying in that growth mindset
to make sure that
your attitude continues to be as
positive as
possible during your software
engineering transition
and honestly that shouldn't stop after
you finish your learning
after you get a job you should still
enjoy i'm kind of talking to myself
here you should still make sure you're
rewarding yourself for knowing more
this week than you did last week and
growing and developing
make sure make sure you stay in that
growth
mindset not in the jumping from
being a nurse to a software engineer in
one year
and just focusing on that leap no
make sure you constantly constantly
constantly think about
what you have accomplished and reward
yourself for that head over to sydney's
channel
and watch the part two of this video
because there's so so much
more mistakes being made and this is
hard enough so you want to make sure
you're giving yourself the best shot
possible and we want to make sure
we are giving you the best shot possible
by telling you these things as well so i
hope you enjoyed the video please like
and subscribe if you haven't already
and i'll see y'all later bye